bio 30 et squeeze aujourd'hui est un
grand jour puisqu'on est sur go étaient
les mots la nouvelle extension de god
simulator les mecs sont allées très loin
puisqu'ils ont décliné le jeu en mmorpg
quel est le phoque donc là on a le choix
entre cinq classes et une classe qui est
une non classe donc il n'est pas une
classe on s'embrouille bêtement la
france il en est d'accord allez au dos a
testé avec ça en premier aux plats ou
regarde on a des sorts et tous au
également des pnj et où dormaient les
mecs sont allés tellement l'on regarde
et on a une quête c'est parti à il faut
que je remette sur sodah au québec est
atteint c'est une quête de qualité quoi
j'ai envie de dire voilà ça vaut
vraiment ok il prend les objets par le
câble du micro c'est génial tiens voilà
ça c'est fait elle est où à tanger car
nous ont mis dans la table elle est où
la femme tu es prêt pour une ré aventure
cette fois bien sûr que oui alors déjà
elle souffre et regarde un petit peu
l'essor de ce micro de bois c'est
classique a pas mal ça veut comme un
bruit de chiotte donc c'est très
clairement une chèvre mais ça à quoi
excuse moi ce pour s'enfuir
je m'en vais mais ça ne peuvent
atteindre jusqu à micro-ondes diabolique
basset partie faut qu'on aille au nord
alors on y va on y va de ce pas de cette
volée nabawi problème c'est que c'est un
peu la tour la direction a la base je
vois une quête va voilà c'est lui le
cousin de la femme du de vous devez
m'aider je suis coincé dans ce tas de
kaka depuis des jours maintenant alors
on fait quoi au voilà mais voilà nickel
mais attendez on est vraiment un héros
quoi on verbaux et robes rouges pas s'il
a l'air en bonne santé maintenant mais
je vois une quête le devoir m'appelle
haut il ya plein de bring 5 apple tout
steve bauer hockey ça marche d'ivoire
qui s'appelle avait gobé le jeu de mots
steve warson ou ramasser des pommes
apple tout d'abord on voit la tatane a
down et level 3 monga micro au niveau 3
qu'est ce qui se passe
salut à y aller bien et je me mets dans
mon inventaire elle g8 boeuf d'euros
l'inventaire quoi ah je vois une quête
la barre loin j'arrive
c'est un désastre et les golfs farmer
sont devenus fous là bas j'en vois pas
pas la balade à travers n'importe où ce
fléau tiens je te casse en deux ben
voilà on est pas mal on tient toute la
route ya un truc au pour soi même et
rien vu venir des à lui on lui envoie
une pizza
ils ont gardé le même bruitages que les
chèvres donc peu importe ce qu'on tue ça
fait un bruit chase 5 sur 5 va zidane en
meneur le monde xp au elle m'a fait
lever la foule est très gentil voilà
pour la récompense et je propose de
l'attraper et un inventaire alors le
plan de bataille est le suivant on doit
infiltrer le village des moûts tout ça
en une technologie très avancée utilise
l'appareil à côté de moi pour infiltrer
village ok c'est une bonne grosse
catapulte quoi waouh quel technologie
révolutionnaire
allez on y va où ok dit qu'elle allait
on y va donc il est au village des
moutons agents espion
hop là où là je suis bloqué dans du bois
merde j'ai le vannes oc
il m'a vu tiens je te vois des pizzas
dessus et quoi lui s'attaquer par un
mouton mais le mec qui forge est un
poisson on rentre à notre match on se
fait attaquer par ton [ __ ] je suis
tellement équipe a donné laquelle je
suis désolé alors ce bol d'or
[ __ ] il a fait une sieste d'un coup au
moral ou la corde de demon's souls a
ramené une sorte de démon john tu vas
pas malgré ces espèces de moutons en
plus tu feras mais mon jeu bonsoir je
cherche une corde de démo est ce qu'on
peut faire passer ça pour une corne de
démons je ne pense pas je me casse dit
si j'en ai marre on va aller faire une
autre quête est ce que tu peux m'en
donnez s'il te plaît l'autre côté de
l'eau il m'emmène au long cours oui tu
m'emmènes dix mois hop là voilà je
préfère me laisser mourir dans le bateau
la discrétion ok on va faire la quête de
ce mec là perdu au milieu de la forêt je
sers cas pas me demander de ramener la
deuxième comme diaboliques on n'a pas
trouvé héros vient ici pour une seconde
je déteste vraiment les ours a pas tué
dix ans pour moi d'accord mais sans
raison quoi tu expliques ama pourrait
tuer des tests juste ok je vous défends
je voulais vous mais pourquoi ils sont
tous mignons des gardes et cherche le
muc et gardes tu la manges et je te
laisse en vie mais c'est des mecs
déguisés en ours en fès mas des sources
et ben oui vous avez dit pas faire des
caméras cachées dans jeu bordel on vous
l'avait dit je dormais disparition nul
tu vois une catho loin le devoir
m'appelle au jeu peut pas prendre mon
inventaire avec moi donc du coup je
devais donner mais si tu aimes le temps
de revenir mais il a rien mais qu'est ce
qui se passe au nom regarder une vanessa
dans la ville et ses blocs et je n'ai
pas le bras assez fort pour le faire est
ce que tu peux m'aider bien sûr au
m'énerve carrément une piétine
maintenant bien sûr que je peux faire ça
pour te regarde comme du muscle et moi
en tant que micro ondes
bien sûr que ça pour toi regarde up et
alors il est content ouais pourquoi tu
as fait ça c'était vraiment important
badé eux moi tu m'as dit de retirer truc
j'ai retiré ces toubibs hop au
regardez reste regardez j'ai fait un
barrage y casse tout cheval en baroeul
voilà un truc dans lequel il va pouvoir
poser c'est à fond mais a fait un autre
va pouvoir passer le portail qui nous
mène
je sais pas trop où up et voilà êtes
vous sûr vouloir voyager oui je suis sûr
bonjour les amis je suis au micro ondes
tu fais cet homme là oh lalala ya un
délire quoi il y en ait arrête tu fais
mal aux oreilles [ __ ] la défense a
coûté moi s'il te plaît voilà merci
on peut par contre percée pour niveau
aussi oui oh tu sais ce pas cela c'est
vous plaît quelqu'un peut m'aider à
sortir de la route dès que je le prenne
avec eux
et là je bouge hop je vais dans mon
inventaire c'est bon t'es plus de deux
ans non pourquoi
mais je trouve défense mois donc jamais
l'odeur de la ville disparition merde ça
peut être marcher allez on fait les
quais de la ville où on travaille dans
celui de rohff magicien ce gros cochon
de lait porc est un magicien
tu es prêt à être un magicien mais il ya
une dernière étape pas tu dois manger
d'autres nourritures sacré alors mange
des chips et bouadi soda mère dimo
gestion logement laisse ton petit frère
ou et la nourriture sacré voilà soya
passé nourriture dans ce coin dont avoir
planqué ripart à salo default swaps à
doit être magicien pour te défoncer opus
tu me fais bien xp comme un gros porc
eux c'est un magicien apprends-moi
apprends moi voilà donc jeté manger et
je te vois le tour spectacle we r d un
peu regardez moi s'il vous plaît à tous
me tourne le dos pour ma personne le
même arrivé que je sorte un peu sur le
bouton alors dit à aucun problème 5000
xp merci mon gars adacore sl fait voler
ok ils s'envolent et je peux essayer
aussi n'ont pas voulu par contre il faut
vraiment qu'ils arrêtent jnk haine tu
arrêtes en renier narines là-bas et on y
va de manière style et comme à chaque
fois ont regardé ça s'annonce
extrêmement épique la reine et gladiator
ça me fait un peu peur déjà comme
ambiance bonjour je suis un simple hobby
tron dont on peut pas tirer les chefs
dans cet endroit a fait face à manger en
eau
tiens je te défonce mois tiens on l'a
battue il m'a dit d'aller à l'ancienne
montagne des chèvres au est toujours
d'attaqué a tant fait pour toi je me
défoncer le droit aux
à bientôt et je parle même avec style
style jugé qu du caca dans mon
inventaire quoi mais vraiment au chic
chic chic chic
attention la grosse connerie oh oui
regardez on est dedans oui bitches sais
quoi je pense qu'il est temps de tester
une autre chèvre magicien sans voix
quand même là patatras les magiciens
alors c'est quoi c'est ce qu'il
voilà une chef qui pèse air eau à temps
mais quel média violence est chef quoi
et aussi j'ai pas précisé mais on n'est
pas du tout avec d'autres joueurs en
ligne
c'est 100% fake même le tchad où tout
est faux tu vois un tour de magie
bah ça c'est bien qu'ils très
impressionnée vous savez bonjour cas et
la télé à al-qaïda contre un arbre
annoncé lui qu'il aime pas allez dégage
voilà on exécute les ordres sans poser
de question bonjour jai ouais merci pour
te remercier je te file dans l'eau et on
chérit bien la voilà vous êtes réunis
pour le restant de vos jours wall amical
il veut un package moteur il veut du
beurre il faut que je ramène du beurre
mais où je trouve du beurre mais il faut
le dire ces choses là où je trouve le
beurre moi je trop là dedans mon avis un
passage secret attendait que fait cet os
ici là doit avoir un passage un truc
c'est sûr je le connais mais que fait
cette chèvre aussi perdre et regardez ce
que je faisais thaler il forge un [ __ ]
de poissons m il forge d'un poisson
c'est scandaleux c'est ta seule chance
de te sentir comme une authentique
sorcières oh oui je suis une sorcière
poirier je finis danse des sicules
bonjour alors il en recherche d'une
assistance vous avez vu mon maître
montré très riches m alors son maître
est bloquée au sommet d'une tour à
l'ouest il veut que je ramène comme ça
il pourra toucher son salaire
ainsi cette tour là on y va on va être
amené ton maître et l'éolien au sommet
de sa mecque assez regardé ça s'écroule
tout s'écroule voilà il va tomber tombe
est mon gars t'inquiète pas où est le
maître à illéla regard des hommes riches
au milieu des cailloux des impôts décédé
mais il est là elle essaie de s'enfuir
regardez le haut attendez mellal assez
unique ce qui se passe
ça a l'air d'avoir incité à aller bien
là et voilà mais que vois-je au loin une
nouvelle quête
apparemment il n'en peut plus du bruit
ça le rend fou et c'est quoi le wii
wheel oui et aucun bruit
ah oui c'est ok d'accord haut arrivent
ou un poisson bon match huawei hausse
est déficiente elle en s'effrayant ses
goûts et ses rues le dernier rail et là
vous avez le volet permet de me voulait
tu te fais gaffe une dernière qui est à
faire aventurier vous avez l'air brave
beaucoup plus que moi même je suis
effrayée je ne sais pas un guerrier et
il ya beaucoup de dangers entre moi et
la cité pensez que vous pouvez m'aider à
aller à la taverne
je vais dans mon inventaire est à mon
avis à mon avis ça c'est pas là pour
rien c'est beau ce qui se passe là vous
avez vu ça en anglais on s'amuse
vous exploitez dans le tram en terre
quoi mais ça s'est un peu plus violent
je trouve c'est ça la taverne papa alors
c'est valider ou pas et à la taverne se
valider ou pas tu vas finir dans le flop
est armé brûle brûle
désolé excuse moi vraiment ouais bah
voila je saisis la fin de cette première
vidéo sur côté mmo une extension bien
marrante et bien prévu que comme on les
aime n'est ce pas j'espère que ça vous a
plu si c'est le cas ne s'était pas mêlé
vidéo comme d'habitude on se retrouve
très vite dans de nouvelles vidéos tient
tout le monde vous êtes top et vous
savez quoi faire avec vos doigts vous
limitez sur les omd 4 points lorsque
soudainement pis voilà
[Musique]